hi everyone i'm david griffin here for
think hero here with my friend Michael
Medina joining us again this time we
talked about video games not going to do
with this a lot of this on think hero
all the time so on talk about the best
video games of 2013 so far yes now I
know if those you out there is a lot of
arcade players of the arcade games to
come on the ps3 network and the xbox
live but we're gonna focus primarily on
Triple A games just because I not really
that knowledgeable about the arcade game
so sorry about that we're gonna say with
the Triple A games and big titles and
big blockbusters I think the first two
they're going to focus on right now or
some of the more popular ones I'm sure
you've heard of and then talk about the
last of us which I'm sorry for you
PlayStation non PlayStation owners have
no chance to play it's an awesome game
and talk about bioshock infinite that's
on both systems so first let's talk
about i know last of us i think you know
it was really special to you so let's
talk about last of us first we're not
going to go into any big spoilers
cherish don't worry about that um i love
the last of us as far as i'm concerned i
mean that's my favorite game so far of
the year I mean that just came from like
that came from start to finish was just
amazing there were so many like you know
what the what moments in that game is so
much fun like the story just kept me
invested all the way throughout and just
like even the multiplayer which you know
really get a chance to check out very
much before what I've heard and stuff is
also really good it just seemed like a
really fully fleshed-out game and I
loved and you know compared to a lot of
other games that kind of try to follow
suit and stuff you know the game
mechanics might be okay what not but the
story never really keeps me invested i
really want to care for these characters
and i felt that i really did you know in
so many occasions i felt like i was
watching a movie they don't play in this
game and you know like i'm a huge fan of
like uncharted and things like that and
that's basically what i felt while
playing this game which makes sense
because it is Naughty Dog right you know
it just goes to show you just how like
amazing these guys are all right I mean
I think that's a game that for me I
always phrase it as it's walking dead at
its best sure when walking dead is at
its best ones having these tough moral
choices about what it is to be human
what is to make moral decisions is it
good to kill somebody if you have to is
it okay like sometimes their
circumstances like it asks all those
questions and the two leads are
incredible it's got acting to ya
BioShock Infinite a little bit and Troy
Baker does the voice of Joel in the last
of us but he also does the voice of
Booker DeWitt
it and bioshock infinite so he's going
to be part of the game of your
conversation no matter what which is
awesome but besides that I mean it's
just such a great game so immersive it
is I think it's the best parts of
walking dead absolutely I just felt like
there were so many cool like um
innovative features in the game so many
things like I really couldn't think of
another game that this game is like I
just think it really does a good job of
borrowing a lot of elements from
different you know there's there's a lot
of like sneaking around then there's a
little bit of gunfire little it's not an
open-world game but kind it's such a big
in that kind of super linear likely not
being likes yeah you have to go to this
one path it's like you're looking around
and if you do look around your reward
mean there's this isn't right they're
not gonna spoil anything but if you do
play the game please take the time to
look around I mean yeah they're
suffering on the walls there's like
there's like a whole story or attention
to DD you can finally just reading some
letters like read the notes if you can
to that super long and they're really
interesting you might find a story about
a whole family yeah you know throughout
the game and I mean it's so many good
easter eggs in there i mean and the
fighting the mechanics are good it's
it's got survival horror like you said
you know it really does different kind
of elements that mixes in it's good it's
fun and again the story is just amazing
just that the intro to the game it's
very nominal right and so that was again
like i said no that kind of limits some
of the gaming world is just Sony but if
you have a friend if you don't if you
can't buy one if you have a friend that
has a PlayStation go over rent it or if
they own it like go play with them
because definitely worth checking out
next for a game with your conversation
remember this is game of the year so far
would you have some games coming out
soon but let's talk about bioshock
infinite Mike and I differ a little bit
on this opinion wise i think i liked a
little bit more but another game that
took risks you know it took or whether
you like it or not it took a lot of
chances it's this kind of beautiful
world of columbia that's in the clouds
that's extremely American racist all
these really interesting issues like
theological issues racial issues all
these only interesting topics disguised
as a shooter but I think trying to deal
with some more heavy subjects you know
like everybody talks about the ending we
can't spoil the ending but like if you
can play the game whether you like or
not try to get to the ending at least
you know to get through it I really like
the game I thought it was a great
experience that's one of my either game
last of us or bioshock 1 i'd be happy
with it but i know you a little
different people see going back to what
you just said my problem is just like I
don't
want to have to play a game that I have
to just get through it just to like
really you know a benefit from the
ending and stuff which by the way the
ending was great it is worth sticking
around but see that was my problem I
felt that you know the gameplay itself
was good it wasn't bad but didn't really
offer me at least anything new and I
felt that the story and I don't know I
guess is this is just their thing
because like even plant going back to
feeling like Bioshock they're very slow
with the way they tell the story of what
not I felt that's kind of what happened
here I felt like you know they were
there were times and I was just kind of
like why am i doing what I'm doing right
now you know like I just didn't feel
again talking about like the last of us
i didn't feel invested in earnest
characters or in this story the ending
is worth it i think i would have
appreciated it more had I really played
the previous two games but if you did
it's definitely worth it but again it
says that's just how I felt it's just a
little too slow for me you know look at
looking at a game like halo 4 you know
it isn't you know try to reinvent the
wheel but the story's just so good it
keeps you wanting to play right so I
mean those are our first I think my guys
both you know my expecially for the last
of us we agree as our top pick for me
Bioshock with all spare topic that was
some other a couple other Triple A games
tomb raider came out very interesting
tomb Raider's is serious i've always
tried not really gotten into it like I
felt like it was a even though it came
out before I was kind like a poor man's
uncharted going to to mater is an older
franchise but I thought like was trying
to be like uncharted and or I guess
intruder was trying to be like Tomb
Raider but did a better job of it um and
then to murder came out this new one and
it was really good I was surprised I
wasn't sure what to expect it it had
elements from uncharted but it still
held its own yeah it's a little more
open world then all the natural do um I
kind of felt the same way about to
murder like you know I remember I had a
friend that was really like in the tomb
raider back in like the late 90s and
loved and stuff and i tried because i
loved action-adventure but for whatever
reason I just couldn't really get into
this series and so that's why I was a
little skeptical Mike all right well it
looks good I'll give it a try i'm glad i
did because the multiplayer I'll you
know was whatever but the single-player
story is phenomenal yeah I wouldn't say
it's not quite on at least for me
uncharted you know cat you know level
right yet but I feel that it's still
really good graphically I thought it
looked great the story was you know fun
and you know the gameplay I thought was
you know kept you wanted to play yeah
for the first time Laura
Laura Laura she's British its Aloha get
his be Laura and its pellets Laura um
she felt like a more human character me
I yeah before she just you know grow
some big boobs and short shorts you know
I just never could take her seriously
but now she was still attractive she's
still pretty but I I sympathize with her
I want to know more about a character
you know she goes to a lot of tough
stuff on this island I hope the next
game is maybe a little more
globe-trotting losing my voice a little
more globe-trotting and less like stuck
on like an island kind of like uncharted
one was more on one location the next
two or more globe-trotting so I'm
excited to see the sequel 14 cents for a
first game to kind of kicking off it's
not a new franchise but it's definitely
a reboot so it makes sense that you
kinda want to start small and then just
kind of go big in the second game but
there's a lot of potential and room for
growth right and so are one of the major
games talk about probably the last game
is a dead space 3 dead space is one of
my kin eyes I know we both enjoy playing
but she played a lot of online just
co-op for this new dead space game this
game was kind of had a tough history i
heard this stuff that game 3 almost
think it made game forward it's her it's
not even in development anymore it's
just you know now i think they're going
to start developing star wars game so
who knows but it's a I loved it was a
sci-fi horror story but a guy named
Isaac Clarke who's just had the worst
luck in the world I mean even the third
game he's getting annoyed like I'm you
guys I mean he's the engineer it's a
typical gamer he pulled around the map
it's like well hey go to ba ba ba ba and
fix this thing's like okay then I mean
you know so I thought it was a fun games
always visually gorgeous great awesome
action see when says if you saw star
trek into darkness yeah the summer that
whole scene with her shooting through
space in their space shoots I mean they
do that and by oh sorry and dead space a
lot and I've always when I saw that seen
them like that's dead space but I mean
what do you think about the franchise
the whole in Dead Space 3 I love the
franchise in general like i said i'd
probably say the first one as far as
like the story goes is probably my
favorite i don't like it was the
scariest of the three I felt like with
tune especially three they try to focus
a little bit more on the action instead
it was more powerful a little bit yeah a
little bit yeah for sure but I thought
graphics were beautiful you know the
story was fun um you know going back to
what you said also about like you know
playing co-op and stuff and
you know we played the DLC that came out
and I which was good but I felt like um
I still felt like the game kind of
lacked a little something I enjoyed I
loved it but I felt like there was
something more that the game should have
provided me with especially like you
said things that we may not get a fourth
game now you know again not to spoil
anything but the the ending of the day
okay for the deal's a deal CR is a
cliffhanger you know it doesn't kind of
doesn't really wrap it up I mean it
doesn't leave it to open right but still
I mean there's like aa you know it's
it's good i want to see more that's
frustrating i mean i hope we get another
one I don't think we will but it was a
fun friend as if you can pick up the
games probably get him cheap right now
they're they're definitely worth playing
they're both out for both systems to
especially the fur again like if first
one reminds me so much of like alien
right you know a little bit of aliens as
well there's so much fun since of course
other games that came out this year
again I sorry for not going to the more
of the arcade games more of the indie
games let's uh any games are huge like
ps4 and their press conference really
getting into the indie games I mean I
just don't play enough indie games so I
can't go into detail about that but you
know there's injustice gods among us you
know as a fighting game strong enough to
win game of the year I mean of course
let us know in the comments what you
think we're also you know looking
forward to the future my kinda talking
about auto theft auto auto 5 we got
watch dogs coming out for both systems
and new and the old that game beyond two
souls will not bow and you know good
cast there from the makers of heavy rain
really immersive experience assassin's
creed 4 black flag SI bus a scree
they're kind of coming new Call of Duty
like not they're not the call to a style
games almost like the new collar that
they want to game out every year now
absolute like so they're really pumping
games out so those are still games to
come out I mean grand theft auto's got
to be the big one coming out in a few
weeks we're all tied that is definitely
the one game I'm really looking forward
to all right yeah so I mean let us know
you think what's your game of the year
so far let me know about the arcade
games you'd say you know David Michael
like check out an arcade game this dark
a game you got a place i'm down to buy
an arcade game on xbox or playstation
store or whatever so as always you can
come chat with us on our youtube pages
think hero pro you also come chat with
us on our website at think hero calm if
you want i was on twitter myself dennis
miking find us at think hero personally
i'm at griffin d i'm at mr. Michael
alexis and we also have a Facebook page
at facebook.com slash think hero fans